dites-moi Vincent vos parents
biologiques ils devaient dégoûter de
vous avoir abandonné il regrette non si
regarde ils vont vous écrire ils vont
envoyer un petit courrier en disant bon
on a changé d'avis ça fait du bien
nettoyer par le public non ah je m'étais
jamais dit la phrase comme ça ouais
temps de Diane
[Applaudissements]
Saint Vincent vous êtes ce soir notre
kikoine de la semaine ce qu'on peut déjà
dire c'est que vous êtes le nouveau
petit protégé de Laurent Ruquier
évidemment ça inquiète beaucoup vos
parents
sont morts de peur ça nous inquiète et
tous c'est normal
[Musique]
Vincent de Diane rebonsoir
vous êtes chroniqueur dans le supplément
l'émission de Maïtena di Rabat le
dimanche sur Canal vous avez succédé à
Stéphane degroute et vous êtes humoriste
vous êtes au petit théâtre et Bertaux
dans un spectacle intitulé s'il se passe
quelque chose mise en scène par François
Rollin et Juliette Chaigneau alors on va
commencer par le spectacle qui est
produit par Laurent Ruquier le dernier
comique produit par Laurent Ruquier
avant nous c'était Éric Zemmour bah il a
fait il a fait une belle carrière oui
mais ça devrait vous inquiéter quand
même
le thème de s'il se passe quelque chose
c'est l'autobiographie et comme vous
l'avez 27 ans le spectacle dure 15
minutes
comme ça on peut dîner tôt
de comédien classique école de théâtre
chômage chômage chômage pièces chiante
chômage
vous m'avez bien suivi
et vous de lancer dans le seul en scène
comme on dit pour pas dire le one man
show avec un spectacle hybride ni stand
up Nice sketch vous jouez beaucoup avec
ça d'ailleurs alors vous racontez dans
le spectacle votre démarche vous voir en
vrai
je suis en train de me dire ça c'est le
vrai challengeance
il y a 3 ans pour raconter votre
adoption alors vérité adopté par un
couple hétérosexuel et pourtant vous
êtes gay vous avez parlé à Christine
Boutin ça mais on doit dîner ensemble là
il faut lui expliquer alors le plus dur
pour vos parents adoptifs c'est le fait
que vous soyez gay ou produit par
Ruquier produit
non ça a été un joli melting pot des
trois angoisses ils sont adorables ils
sont adorables dites-moi à Vincent vos
parents biologiques ils devaient
dégoûter de vous avoir abandonné il
regrette non si regarde ils vont vous
écrire ils vont envoyer un petit
courrier en disant bah on a changé
d'avis quand on a refait là ça fait du
bien
ah je m'étais jamais dit la phrase comme
ça ouais ouais
vous êtes adopté par le public et vous
êtes aussi adopté par la presse vous
avez des critiques absolument
extraordinaires les gens remarquent la
finesse qu'il y a quand même c'est pas
du zival c'est non non j'aime pas ça
comme spectateur j'aime pas quand on
quand je sens le type sur scène qui est
préoccupé par le fait que ça soit drôle
tout les trois secondes moi si c'est pas
drôle pendant pendant une minute si la
phrase me plaît quand même si c'est
singulier si c'est intéressant ça me va
alors il y a ça il y a aussi la télé le
supplément le succédé à Stéphane de
Groodt et qui est parti pourquoi Raymond
Devos tu as fait un procès à titre
posthume
en fait chaque semaine la bio interdite
d'un invité avec Attali c'était chaud
vous avez dit qu'il ressemblait à hibou
et il a il l'a mal pris il a très j'ai
vu dans son œil que ça lui faisait de la
peine et ça m'a figé alors Éva jolie
vous dites je trouve que vous ressemblez
à une prof d'allemand enfin une prof
d'allemand qui cherche vraiment à faire
régner un peu d'ordre dans sa classe de
4e B alors qu'elle est à de la retraite
mais c'est tellement juste Estrosi le
petit garçon à roulettes qu'il faisait
vroum vroum en écoutant les forbans à
laisser la place au Corleone de la
région PACA
et alors je termine avec Najat c'est
très sympa avec Najat hein c'était la
première émission c'était mon baptême
les deux jumeaux vous lui dites qui
respectent scrupuleusement la parité
puisque l'un est un garçon fille et
l'autre une fille garçon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu